pire avec new line morissette biologie
spécialisée même faire morin à la
morissette bonsoir bonsoir que je vous
parle en direct de rimouski c'est un
plaisir de sentir l'air de chez vous
jusqu'à chez nous oui on le sent je
l'imaginé alors d'abord qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait là c'est quoi votre
théorie vous mangez une question avant
une baleine une orque a la bosse de 3 en
deux ou trois ans est ce qu'elle vit
encore avec ses parents comme les petits
ours qui vivent longtemps où elle est
autonome à stage leurs habitudes
normalement les baleines à cet âge là
sont sevrés donc ils ont plus besoin de
leur mère mais c'est des animaux qui ont
des comportements sociaux quand même
assez important
donc normalement dépendamment des
espèces est vraiment des clans qui des
unités familiales qui est qui se crée cc
c'est d'autant plus vrai chez d'autres
espèces comme les épaulards mais même
chez les baleines à bosse on voit
souvent des groupes familiaux à être
ensemble
mais au niveau de la survie à deux trois
ans c'était pas un animal qui dépendent
être sa mère ok donc elle pouvait elle
était sevrée comme vous dites mais
habituellement on continue à vivre dans
le clan dans la famille
oui ben c'est des animaux qui vivent en
groupe 1 il se retrouve à peu près au
même endroit pour s'alimenter souvent un
groupe aussi donc une baleine solitaire
comme ça c'est très très rare
très bien alors l'autre question que
faisais tu es là montréal passe quand
même un bon boulot ces animaux là ont un
sens sont des radars
qu'est ce qu'elle faisait si bas c'est
très très difficile d'avoir une réponse
exacte pour ça mais des animaux vagabond
des baleines ou d'autres espèces
animales ça arrive des animaux qui se
retrouvent à des endroits où ils
devraient pas être normalement bain
rendu là
ils sont confrontés un peu aux lois de
la sélection naturelle et puis des
erreurs de parcours ou des erreurs de
décision qu'ils auront pris qui les
auront mené dans des habitats comme ceux
qui sont pas les leurs donc c'est très
difficile d'expliquer pourquoi s est
rendu là peut-être que je suivais de la
nourriture peut-être qu'elle a été
effrayé par quelque chose déranger ou
peut-être que c'est un jeune en
apprentissage qui a pris les mauvaises
décisions aussi
ou peut-être qu'elle avait des problèmes
cérébraux contacté dans le film n'est
mollahs doris le poisson qui se perd l
oubli est-ce que ça arrive
il peut avoir des troubles mais quand on
regarde souvent séché des espèces de
cétacés comme les dauphins il ya
effectivement moyen de regarder si
y'avait pas des problèmes d'orientation
quelque chose dans leur système nerveux
qui leur faisait un peu perdre le radar
donc ça c'est une des hypothèses mais
souvent personnellement je pense que
comme c'est un jeune
puis comme des animaux vagabond ça
arrive c'est un cas d'exception comme on
en voit régulièrement chez plusieurs
espèces animales puis faut ne faut
peut-être pas chercher plus loin qu'ils
ont rejoint terme écologique fait c'est
vous êtes arrivés l'un est arrivé là
mais le lot qui est pas sali
combien de temps elle aurait pu veiller
à ce que ce type de leur cas la bosse
plus quand même vivre très longtemps
dans de l'eau qui n'est pas sale et pas
très longtemps parce que il n'y a aucune
espèce de baleine qui est fait pour
survivre dans de l'eau salée
il ya quelques années au dos dans le dos
dans le dos de l'eau douce oui et
quelques espèces de dauphins qui peuvent
faire ça comme un dauphin d'ailleurs en
amazonie qui vit dans des rivières
mais pour les baleines les grands
cétacés aucune espèce de baleine est
capable de survivre dans un milieu comme
ça ce qui peut arriver est un peu restée
là quelques semaines mais à long terme
pour du long terme c'est vraiment pas un
environnement qui est viable ou non à ce
que ça fait qu'est ce que ça lui fait de
l'eau douce
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça change en
fait juste au niveau de la nourriture
c'est pas un écosystème qui ai fait mon
supporter son alimentation normale
ça à court terme c'est pas si grave
parce que ces baleines là quand elles
vont dans le sud l'hiver et mange
pratiquement pas elles sont à peu près
10% de leur jeu leur régime alimentaire
quand elles reviennent nous voir par
contre c'est parce que on est au regard
de manger puis elles viennent parce
qu'ils ont faim puis c'est le moment de
s'alimenter dans leurs années de vie
donc elle peut pas rester très longtemps
dans un habitat où il n'y a pas vraiment
la nourriture adéquate pour elle
l'autre chose que ça peut faire le dos
et créer à long terme des maladies peau
ce qui n'était pas encore le col pour
cette baleine ne semblait être quand
même en bonne santé
puis un autre truc qui est probablement
est inquiétant à long terme c'est que
l'eau salée versus l'eau douce bas on
n'a pas la même flottabilité et puis
pour une baleine de cette taille là
malgré le fait qu'elle soit adaptée à la
nage peut-être peut-être c'est
probablement pas la cause principale
mais peut-être que cest ça devient plus
difficile de nager dans l'eau douce pour
l'innovation et la r mon hôte est donc
lé était dans bonne direction a remonté
le fleuve pour les verts cultivés au
québec chez vous mais elle était dans la
voie maritime jallerat donc elle a
heurté un navire mais manifestement oui
il semblerait qu'il y ait une vie c'est
la cause la plus probable la nécropsies
à date d'une collision avec les navires
mais vous savez ces cétacés leurs
principales causes de mortalité peu
importe où elles sont peexme leur arrive
dans la vie c'est pratiquement toujours
des causes d'origine humaine
donc il ya des encadrements dans des
engins de pêche qui était un peu moins
une menace dans le coin de montréal
parce que c'est pas nous sommes de pêche
qui est très importante mais sinon
interaction avec les humains dérangement
par le bruit collision avec des navires
si cette baleine l'avait à mourir on
était probablement assez certains que ça
allait être une cause d'origine humaine
malheureusement c'était de notre faute
bon je vais vous montrer le tableau
quand on va dans
convoyage qu'on va dans votre coin peel
plus bas encore on voit dans à peu près
tous les hôtels les baleines du
saint-laurent mon petit rorqual rorqual
commun rocade lui rocade à bosse or
qu'est la poste mais le gars cachalots
et paulhan marsouins dauphins
la bonne nouvelle c'est clair qu'elle a
à bosse ça va bien la population oui
c'est une espèce qui après avoir été
assez décimé du temps de la chasse est
bien remonté à force d'efforts de
conservation fi de tout ce qu'on a fait
pour essayer de protéger cette baleine
là c'est pas le cas de toutes les
espèces que vous voyez sur votre tableau
parce que des treize espèces de c'est
ainsi qu'on a dans le saint-laurent il y
en a la moitié qui sont en péril pour
différentes raisons
donc c'est une mortalité qu'on a vu à
montréal qui est anecdotique qui est
très triste et très difficile de voir
c'est évidemment mais des baleines il y
en a plusieurs qui sont menacés puisque
c'est leur quotidien d'être menacée à
une mortalité comme ça et sont les plus
menacés madame mauricette chez nous là
le rorqual bleu dont on n'entend
pratiquement jamais parlé parce que
c'est des baleines qui meurt un peu dans
l'oubli et flotte pas elles vont couler
au fond on les voit rarement morte
donc elles ont elles ont pas ce pouvoir
là de nous scandaliser quand tu meurs
sinon la baleine noire dont on a parlé
plusieurs fois dans les dernières années
à cause de deux salles son retour dans
le golfe du saint laurent et ses
interactions avec les pêcheurs entre
autres c'est une baleine dont il reste
400 individus donc très en voix de
disparition le béluga dans le saint
laurent dont on entend souvent parler
aussi est une espèce qui est en voie de
disparition
donc il y en a la moitié de nos cétacés
que pour lesquelles ça va pas très bien
en ce moment
bon donc on peut pas dire que le tableau
pour tout le monde et jolie voix dans la
bonne les choses vont dans la bonne
direction le dialogue oui
d'autres noms là oui exactement puis
évidemment mais ceux pour qui ça va bien
ça demeure des vitrines incroyable de la
preuve de ce qu'on peut faire quand on
se donne la peine de les protéger
la baleine à bosse en est un bel exemple
c'est un ambassadeur c'est un exemple de
ce qu'on a réussi à faire à force de
deux d'efforts de conservation
il faut faire la même chose pour les
autres espèces pour lesquelles on se
désole pas autant parce que et son poids
à montréal en train de se donner en
spectacle puis à attirer l'attention
mais on a des espèces de cétacés qui ce
qui forge notre économie qui avait qui
attire le logo de mieux quoi faire de
mieux
l'île maurice est honteux et je pense
que la clé c'est de travailler ensemble
et puis pour ces espèces là on n'a pas
vraiment le luxe ou le temps de se
chicaner a pointé des coupables faut les
meilleurs connaisseurs de la situation
c'est les gens de l'industrie qui sont
sur le terrain puis la meilleure
solution ou les choses les plus
efficaces qu'on peut faire mais il va
falloir les faire en concertation pour
s'assurer que tout le monde qui a des
idées puissent mettre la main à la pâte
pour trouver des solutions à ces as à la
protection de ces baleines l'opinion
alors en 30 secondes comment vous
expliquer ma morissette sur le lien
affectif que les hommes ont vis-à-vis
les baleines dont le vul depuis quelques
jours ben c'est des animaux qui sont
très charismatique un puits qui
supportent souvent un écosystème au
complet quand on a des baleines dans un
écosystème ça veut dire que le reste va
bien aussi donc c'est des ambassades à
puis ça nous ça nous productions veut
protéger les baleines ben on protège
aussi tout le reste donc pour nous c'est
des espèces qui sont extrêmement
importantes pas juste parce qu'ils sont
belles mais parce qu'elle protège le
reste de l'écosystème quelque chose de
noble dans leur présence et les
morissette c'est toujours un plaisir
merci beaucoup s'est arrêté aux gens de
la rue mode de rimouski merci oui au
revoir